all right we now turn to more far left
and this is lunacy out of California get
this one San Francisco's reparations
committee is proposing a whopping 5
million dollars to each black long-time
resident not five million total five
million dollars to each black resident
including total debt forgiveness but
that's not all the plan also calls for
the city to supplement lower income
black recipients annually for the next
250 years
where is all this money going to come
from here for reaction Fox News
contributor Leo Terrell and Epic Times
host Larry Elder uh Leo Leo how
does every bad idea come out of
California and how how do they imagine
this would get implemented
so first of all it's not going to ever
get implemented I'll be the first lawyer
to fight against this Pete Larry this is
outrageous it's unlawful it's
unconstitutional it's racist but it's
not surprising it came from California
on the day of MLK's life birthday we're
talking about a racist program to
benefit individuals who happen to be
black five million dollars California
was a free state well who's going to pay
for it why should they get five million
because of skin color it's insulting
it's racist and I'll tell you right now
this state a couple of years ago try to
pass prop 16 an old version of
affirmative action it lost even though
that meant that there was same Democrats
who knew it's unfair to benefit one
group over another because of skin color
one last Point somebody said judge a
person by the character of his conduct
not the color of his skin and that is a
person that we should be following not
giving people about five million dollars
based on skin color it's outrageous
well and that's the person we honor
today on this holiday Martin Luther King
Jr and and Larry but this is we laugh
and rightfully so this is but this is
exactly what large portions of the
Democrat Party would like to push
politically not just in San Francisco
and elsewhere is
taxpayers pay for the sins of the past
as if that's going to make things better
yeah you know reparations is the
extraction of money from people who are
never slave owners to be given to people
who were never slaves uh and Pete and
Leo what I want to know is do I get the
5 million on top of the 233 000 that
Gavin newsom's task force already said
that we get and this business about
supplementing income for the next 250
years where did that come from America
wasn't a country until 1789 uh slavery
ended in 1865 that's 76 years so that's
kind of Fuzzy Math and as you pointed
out Leo California was not a slave state
San Francisco was not a slave City
Michael MedVet says only about five
percent of white Americans have any sort
of generational connection to slavery so
why should everybody else pay
furthermore slavery was a Democrat
institution why don't Democrats play Jim
Crow was a Democrat institution why
don't Democrats play very few
Republicans own slaves watch the
Republicans pay a dime the whole thing
is absolutely insulting what's next
they're going to give Mexico California
back to Mexico
I mean honestly
one other thing go ahead Leo yeah
America does not have a race issue
America has a race card issue because
the Democrats need to play the race card
they need to keep blacks on the
government payroll because without the
black population there's no Democratic
party they have a race car issue and
they're never going to let that card go
where this country has no systemic
racism that's something in 1955 and 2023
we have no institutionalized racism but
you can't tell that to a Democrat
Leo would you would you agree I mean
that's a that's that is a uh a strong
statement saying hey this is this is
this is being made up to further divide
us
absolutely of course absolutely I want
to make sure it's all it's all the way
I'm sorry Larry
I'm going to say it's all about making
sure that the Democrats keep getting
that monolithic black vote about 95
without which they cannot win so instead
of concentrating on the number one
problem facing the black community which
is the absence of fathers the fact that
85 percent of black 8th graders are
neither math nor reading grade
proficient let's not talk about that
let's not talk about crime going on in
the urban areas let's talk about
nonsense like making other people who
have nothing whatever to do with with
Jim Crow and slavery pay money to black
people in order for them to keep getting
the black vote as Leo pointed out
Leo and Larry two great Americans great
to talk to you tonight thanks for being
here hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else